When you reach a certain level of wealth,
you start to feel like nothing can touch you.
You spit sunshine and crap gold.
At least, that’s been my experience.
Can’t imagine any of you can relate.
But please, allow me to explain how it feels
when there’s three commas in your bank balance.
I know time is money, but don’t worry, I’m
good for it.
Or at least, I thought I was, before that
night...
Point is, the more money you get, the higher
you climb that golden ladder, the stronger
the feeling of security gets.
Money can’t buy happiness, or so the saying
goes, but trust me when I say that it can
buy everything else.
And that’s pretty close.
That’s right, I’m one of the dreaded one
percent: a straight-up billionaire, baby.
Don’t get me wrong, I’m not some guy who
was born with a silver spoon in my mouth.
I worked hard!
I was lucky, of course, and I had some help
from my parents, but who didn’t get a little
help from their families while growing up?
After my dad helped me get into an Ivy League
school, and gave me a 20 million dollar loan
as a graduation present, I was completely
on my own.
I scraped, and I saved, and I turned that
loan into the biggest tech conglomerate in
the entire world.
After I made my first hundred million, I stopped
worrying about being successful enough, driven
enough, good enough.
After my first billion?
I felt like I could do anything.
And honestly, I could.
The money stopped feeling real, stopped being
anything except a number ticking ever upward,
and signifying that I would never run out
of points in the game of life.
I had won.
I purchased myself a rocket with a velvet
interior, for luxury space travel.
I filled a room in my house with vintage guitars
that had all previously been touched by members
of The Beatles, just because I could.
I moved into a cottage in Tuscany, a house
in Martha’s Vineyard, a beach house in Hawaii,
my Los Angeles mansion, and my favorite, a
villa in the South of France.
That’s not all of them, of course, but those
are my top five.
If you ever get the chance to have a house
on every continent, I highly recommend it.
Just kidding, I know most people won’t get
the chance.
But maybe if you’re lucky, you’ll get
an invitation to one of my legendary parties.
If you’re luckier than lucky, you’ll find
yourself with an invitation to my annual costume
party.
It's an incredible spectacle every year, and
this year was no exception.
Picture it: me, my beautiful wife - an international
supermodel, thank you very much - and a few
hundred of our closest friends gathered at
my home nestled right up against the French
Riviera.
The theme was “masquerade ball”, and the
dress code was strict.
No one would be admitted without a mask or
attire elegant enough for the party.
Inside, what greeted them was nothing short
of absolute opulence.
I instructed my party planner to spare no
expense.
The ballroom was outfitted with a massive
Swarovski chandelier, thousands of candles
lighting the room, flames sparkling in the
crystal, and filling the room with warm light.
In the corner, a string quartet borrowed from
the National Opera of Paris played next to
one of six - count them, six - champagne fountains.
I commissioned a portrait of me and my wife,
dressed to the nines and wearing our masks,
and hung it in the entryway to greet my guests.
In the dining room, guests could sit down
to a feast fit for Louis XIV, complete with
30 courses including pheasant, pate, poached
pears, whole roasted boar, and other dishes
inspired by the Palace of Versailles.
For party goers with more modern palates,
the molecular gastronomy room was open with
a chef on-site to serve flavored foams and
vaporized cocktails.
Or, those who wanted to stick to the ballroom
could enjoy the passed-around hors d'oeuvres.
But really, why choose?
If they wanted, they could have a bit of everything.
Or a lot of it.
Money was truly no object.
The party was going great.
I was wearing my favorite suit, which cost
more than most people spend on a house, and
a custom-designed mask made from hundreds
of black and white diamonds, with a few red
diamonds thrown in for a pop of color - and
because they’re the rarest variety of diamond
in the world.
The more you know, right?
My guests had all arrived, and guards were
stationed at all entrances to make sure no
party crashers tried to make their way inside
and take advantage of my hospitality and generosity.
So, imagine my surprise when, long after the
guest list had been completely checked off,
a mysterious figure swept in and interrupted
everything.
My wife elbowed me in the side as I was helping
myself to some beluga caviar.
“Who is that?”
she hissed to me, tilting her head toward
the doorway at the other end of the ballroom.
I turned, expecting to see a foreign dignitary
or oil baron she had forgotten the name of,
but instead, I saw something much more bizarre.
There, standing like a shadow in a room full
of silk and gold, was a person dressed in
thick black robes.
They were wearing a mask, but it was unsettling
to look at.
Intense dark eyes peered out of pale ceramic
that tapered into a long, pointed beak.
I dimly remembered drawings of Medieval doctors
wearing masks like those as the Black Plague
decimated Europe.
This was just some edgy party crasher, looking
for attention, I knew that, but looking at
them…a chill ran up my spine.
“How did he get in?”
I shook my head, motioning to one of the security
guards stationed near the entrance.
Do your jobs, fellas.
Come on.
Rob, my beefiest guard, got the signal and
approached the crasher.
I took a sip of my drink, eager to watch this
wannabe cool guy get booted from my world.
He watched Rob come closer as he stood completely
still, little black eyes unblinking.
What was this guy’s deal?
He reached out one black-gloved hand and touched
Rob’s throat with one finger.
As soon as the stranger touched his skin,
Rob dropped to the ground, unmoving.
He was all the way on the other side of the
room, but somehow I just knew: he was dead.
As soon as Rob fell, the party came to a screeching
halt.
My wife screamed and tugged on my arm, but
I couldn’t take a step.
I just watched, frozen in place, as the stranger
in the Plague Doctor mask pulled a syringe
from a pocket in his robes and injected something
thick and black into Rob’s corpse.
What had just been a mound of dead flesh began
to thrash around, hands grasping at nothing,
legs kicking, and something that looked like
Rob, but was definitely not him, climbed to
its feet.
It had his face, his body, but its eyes were
hollow and dead.
There was no light behind them, they were
just flat.
The thing that once was Rob began to shuffle
into the room, the stranger trailing behind
it.
As he walked, he touched guests with his gloved
hands.
Like Rob, they dropped to the ground, dead
at a single touch.
Guests began to scatter in every direction,
running for their lives.
Still, I couldn’t get myself to move.
A dozen people were dead on the floor.
Then two dozen.
Then three.
As he walked, the stranger injected them with
more of the strange liquid, and the dead guests
shambled to their feet or dragged themselves
along the floor with stiff, pale fingers.
The shuffling corpses that were once my friends
grabbed guests near them with inhuman strength
as they tried to run away, dragging them toward
the horrible Doctor so he could kill and transform
them too.
I had to make a break for it, I had to get
out of there, but my legs wouldn’t listen
to me.
Fear and morbid curiosity froze me to the
spot.
There had to be at least fifty zombies by
now, and the Doctor just kept going.
He was getting closer and closer to me, hand
outstretched and ready to deliver its deadly
touch.
I unstuck my tongue from the roof of my mouth,
swallowed, and spoke.
“Why are you doing this?”
The Doctor paused, tilting his head to the
side in thought.
“This home is overrun with the Pestilence.
It is my duty to contain its spread and treat
the infected.”
He spoke formally, in a voice that reverberated
from inside the mask with a metallic edge.
“They must be cured.”
I had to think fast.
I could talk my way out of this.
I’ve sold companies, made mergers, avoided
paying taxes my whole life.
Now I just had to negotiate for my own life.
My friends might be gone, but I could at least
save myself.
“You’re a Doctor,” I said.
He seemed pleased at this.
“I am a physician, yes,” he said.
“You’re trying to help,” I continued.
“Yes, I see you too are a man of science,”
He had stopped coming closer, the zombies
had stopped advancing on me.
It was working.
“I don’t know if you’re aware of this,
but I’m a very wealthy man, Doctor,” I
took a drink of my champagne, doing my best
to appear casual, friendly even.
“I’m sure you’re in need of funding,
for your mission?
Perhaps we could work together?”
“You wish to aid me in my mission?”
The Doctor asked.
“I do,” I lied.
“I’m in great health, as you can see,
but I don’t want a…pestilence spreading
around and infecting me or my loved ones.
I’d like to help you.”
I paused, searching for the right words.
“I could be your Patron?”
The Doctor clapped his gloved hands together,
and I could have sworn he smiled beneath his
beaked visage.
“Excellent!
This is the most fortuitous meeting indeed,
I am glad to have found you here Sir.
If you would come with me, we may begin our
work!”
He turned and swept out of the room, gesturing
for me to follow.
I looked around for an exit route, a way to
make a break for it, but there were too many
corpses ready to grab me with inhuman strength
and drag me to certain death.
The room was filled with them, shuffling about
in their torn formal wear, slackened jaws
hanging loose and hollow eyes watching me.
I had no choice but to follow this guy and
just wait for my opportunity to get away.
I don’t know how long we walked down the
narrow town streets in the dark.
Every time we passed an alley I thought I
could duck down, the Doctor got closer to
me with his deadly hands or a group of zombies
encircled me.
I was outside, I should have been home free,
but there was nowhere to run.
Eventually, the Doctor stopped in front of
an abandoned, dilapidated house.
The paint was peeling off the walls, and there
was a hole that rotted through the ceiling.
“Welcome, Sir, to my Laboratory.”
He made a grand, sweeping gesture, inviting
me to walk through the door.
I obeyed, crossing the threshold.
The smell of rot and dried blood hit me so
hard that I thought I might throw up.
The house was dark, I had to squint to see,
but I could make out scattered piles of body
parts, animal and human.
There was a table covered with surgical equipment,
and, next to it, a black leather doctor’s
bag.
There were people in here, too.
Or they used to be people.
They were silent zombies, like the others.
Some stood along the walls at silent attention,
others were lying on the ground hooked up
to IVs full of strange liquid, or strapped
to gurneys ready to be operated on.
“This looks great.”
My voice shook, but I hoped he wouldn’t
notice.
“With my funds, we can upgrade your lab,
get you to a more high-tech facility.
Better lighting, more space, research assistants…”
“Excellent!
Together, we will eradicate the Pestilence
once and for all.”
“There” The Doctor pointed at the medical
table to my right.
“Grab a pair of gloves and slide them on.”
The Doctor nodded, as I squeezed my hands
into a pair of rubber medical gloves.
“Absolutely!
Can you show me more of what you’re working
on?”
Good thinking.
When his back was turned, I would run out
the door and get to safety.
The Doctor approached the table covered with
tools, and bent to pick up a scalpel.
Now was my moment.
I ran toward the door, as fast as my legs
would carry me.
I collided with something hard and cold.
It was Rob, my old bodyguard, doing what he
did best: keeping the perimeter secure.
“Sir?
Where are you going?”
The Doctor called.
“Are you…trying to abandon our work?”
He paused for a moment, realizing what I had
done.
“Did you deceive me?”
His voice turned cold, angry.
“No, I-“ I couldn’t come up with a lie.
Rob wrapped his arms around my chest, holding
me in place as the Doctor approached me with
the scalpel in hand.
“You are not looking well, my friend…Perhaps
you have fallen ill.
Such a shame, I had looked forward to our
collaboration.”
He drew the scalpel, stretching his hand out
toward my neck.
I thrashed around, arms flailing, and grabbed
at his mask with gloved hands.
What did this monster look like underneath?
Who was he?
What was he?
The mask did not budge, and I realized…this
was no mask.
It was his face.
“Don’t worry.”
His blade sliced into the side of my neck.
“I will make you well again.”
His pitch-black eyes twinkled as he set to
work.
Then everything went dark...
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” and “SCP-049 - What Actually
is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
for more stories of this not-so-good doctor!